I worked for a short time as a lawyer in
the general practice firm and I would
get there in the morning and go into my
office and sit there and sort of wait
for the day in the day past interminably
now I sit down for very short periods of
time I'm running around I'm always
there's always three more things to do
than I could possibly do at the same
moment but then again it's that sort of
pace especially in New York City and
also the fact that early on I was able
to find that I got satisfaction of
getting good results for my clients so
that's kept me doing it a lot of the
work that I get I'm like in most
criminal defense lawyers I receive
assignments from the court the federal
court the state court and then clients
find me to hire me I've been around for
21 years so word-of-mouth people come to
me
well first you have to be able to make
some connection with your client have
them have some level of trust with you
and then you have to be able to assess
the case independently of that
relationship and try to discuss with
your client what the possible outcomes
are what the best results are because
it's always the risk is always the
client no matter what happens I know I
go home but I think the ability to to be
able to assess a case as it goes along
and to determine what the best course is
and to have your client trust you enough
to listen to your advice I tried a
number of drug cases because that's what
most of the criminal justice system is
and they have interesting elements but I
don't know if the facts themselves just
looking at them are are particularly
interesting I tried an attempted murder
case where my client stabbed someone
very severely and it turned out that
really he was in the wrong place and and
he was set upon by a group of actually
well-educated college students who
didn't like him because of his ethnicity
and we Brea were able to present a self
defense a successful self defense there
and it was unusual because it was a case
where a poor person was able to to
overcome that maybe stigma and show that
these drunken Oh wealthy college
students were really the person that
started it I've tried a number of other
cases right now I'm sort of drawing a
blank as to what's interesting but in
each case there is always something that
you know I try to focus on or it becomes
favorable for the defense and it's if
it's a tiny crack I try to spend the
whole
trial widening that crack because all I
really need to do is show that there's a
reasonable doubt well early on that
decision in my career that decision
really meant nothing it may make a
difference as to how I advise my client
as to whether the case against he or she
is strong but my job is to defend the
person that I either am hired to
represent or appointed to represent to
the best of my ability within the bounds
of the canons of ethics and it really
doesn't matter factually whether you
know they're guilty or not guilty that's
really for the Trier of fact to decide a
judge or a jury and I never it doesn't
really make a difference to me
you